so we need to figure out what 46 plus 43
is let me write it down again and if
I'll write it like this
46 plus 43 and what we do here is we
just first look at the ones place we
already have six ones plus three ones or
you could say 6 & 3 and 6 plus 3 is just
9 6 plus 3 is 9 so we have 9 ones and
then you have you go to the tens place
and there's two ways to think about it
you could view this as 4 plus 4 is equal
to 8 but really the reality of what
we're doing since we're operating in the
tens place this is really 40 plus 40 is
equal to 80 and we could do the same
problem expand it out this is the same
thing as 40 plus 6 we've seen this
before right that's what 46 is and then
43 is the same thing as 40 plus 3 40
plus 3 we've expanded these out before
and so when you add them when you add a
6 plus a 3 when you add a 6 plus a 3 you
get a 9 and when you had a 40 plus a 40
you get an 80 you get an 80 so you get
80 plus 9 which is 89 and the whole
reason why I did this is I wanted to
show you that you really because when
you're adding 4 is in the 10 place
you're really adding 40s the fact that
it's in the tens place represents that
or the fact that the 4 is in the tens
place shows that it represents 40 the
fact that the eights there shows that it
represents 80